ISSA AND MORE.
IT’S AN IMPORTANT HOUR BUT
FIRST MY OPEN.
YOU CAN’T KEEP AMERICANS DOWN.
BORN OF REBELLION AND
REVOLUTION, WE ARE READY TO
FIGHT.
IT’S IN OUR DNA.
WE ARE READY TO FIGHT THE VIRUS
AND READY TO FIGHT TO REOPEN OUR
COUNTRY IN A SAFE AND STRATEGIC
WAY.
WE GET IT, WE ARE NOT STUPID.
WE KNOW TO WASH OUR HANDS, WEAR
A MASK, AND KEEP OUR DISTANCE.
WE KNOW TO LOOK FOR SIGNS OF THE
VIRUS.
WE LOOK TO PROTECT THE
VULNERABLE.
WE APPRECIATE THE NUMBERS TO BE
CONTAINED AS WE GO THROUGH THE
THREE PHASES OF REOPENING.
WE NOTE VIRUS CAN COME BACK AND
WE’LL BE VILLAGE LENGTH TO MAKE
SURE A COMPLETE REOPENING IS
DEPENDENT UPON THE DATA.
WE HAVE BEEN SHELTERED IN PLACE
FOR WEEK AND WE ARE NOT
CHILDREN.
WE ARE CAPABLE OF USING OUR
GOD-GIVEN COMMON SENSE TO
PROTECT OURSELVES AND OTHERS.
BUT THERE HAS TO BE A BALANCE
BETWEEN PHYSICAL SAFETY AND
ECONOMIC SURVIVE.
MORE AND MORE PEOPLE COMING
UNEMPLOYED.
2 MILLION SO FAR.
-- 22 MILLION SO FAR.
PEOPLE WATCHED THEIR SAVINGS AND
THEIR DREAMS DISAPPEAR.
FOR SOME THERE WILL BE NO
BUSINESS TO REBUILD.
FOR OTHERS THERE WILL BE NO
COMING BACK FROM THE DEPTHS OF
DEPRESSION, ALCOHOL OR DRUG
ABUSE.
CANCELED ELECTRICKIVE SUM ARE
YOUS PROLONGED ENORMOUS PHYSICAL
PAIN, DISTRESS AND DEPRESSION.
NAVY SHIPS CONTINUED INTO
HOSPITALS SENT AT THE REQUEST OF
PANICKED GOVERNORS REMAINED
ESSENTIALLY EMPTY ON BOTH
COASTS.
BUT SOME THINK THE NANNY STATE
IS THE ANSWER.
BUT DATA SUGGESTS THE VIRUS IS
LESS THAN THEY THOUGHT.
INFLATED NUMBERS, ENOUGH.
ENOUGH OF THE LOCKDOWN.
THE DECLARATION OF INDEPENDENCE
GIVES US THE RIGHT TO LIFE,
LIBERTY AND THE PURSUIT OF
HAPPINESS.
INCLUDING THE RIGHT TO SURVIVE,
LIVE FREELY AND CARE FOR OUR
FAMILIES.
IT DOES NOT GIVE GOVERNORS THE
RIGHT TO IMPOSE NANNY STATES,
REDUCE LIBERTIES AND ENLARGE
GOVERNMENT POWER.
CERTAINLY GOVERNMENT HAS THE
AUTHORITY TO PROTECT PUBLIC
HEALTH DURING A PANDEMIC.
BUT THAT POWER CANNOT BE USED TO
NULLIFY CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS,
INCLUDING THE RIGHT OF PEACEFUL
PROTEST WHEN CIVIL LIBERTIES ARE
AT STAKE.
ENOUGH OF THESE SMALL-TIME
POLITICIANS USING THIS PANDEMIC
TO FLEX THEIR PATHETIC MUSCLES
IN ORDER TO GAIN ATTENTION.
LIKE TICKETING CITIZENS FOR
ATTENDING CHURCH SERVICES ON
CHURCH PROPERTY IN THEIR OWN
CARS?
LIKE ARRESTING AND HANDCUFFING A
FATHER IN FRONT OF HIS CHILDREN
FOR PLAYING CATCHOUT DOORS?
LIKE PROHIBITING CITIZENS THE
RIGHT TO PURIFIER ARMS?
TAKE GRETCHEN WHITMER
AUDITIONING TO BE THE VP
CANDIDATE BE ON THE JOE BIDEN
TICKET.
SHE ISSUES GUIDELINES THAT ARE
LAUGHABLE IF THE SITUATION WERE
NOT SO DEADLY SERIOUS.
HER ACTIONS DISCRIMINATORY AND
POINT BLANK UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
SHE SAYS IT’S OKAY TO BUY
ALCOHOL, AND LOTTERY TICKETS.
SHE KEEPS ABORTION CLINICS OPEN
TO GET AN ABORTION.
BUT DON’T YOU DARE EVEN THINK
ABOUT GOING TO CHURCH.
AND SHE MUST BE AS SHE DECREES
FROM ON HIGH THAT YOU CAN BUY
WEED, BUT NOT GRASS SEED OR
VEGETABLE SEED.
YOU CAN STAY IN YOUR HOME, BUT
DON’T THINK ABOUT BUYING PAINT
TO FIX IT UP.
SHE RULED HOME IMPROVEMENT
STORES CAN STAY OPEN, BUT THEY
HAD TO CLOSE THE AREAS THAT HAD
FLOORING OR GARDENING SECTIONS.
WHAT DOES SHE DO WHEN PEOPLE
COME OUT AND PROTEST TO EXERCISE
THEIR CIVIL LIBERTIES?
SHE DOUBLES DOWN.
GRETCHEN.
YOUR VP AUDITION AIN’T GOING SO
WELL.
NEW JERSEY GOVERNOR PHIL MURPHY
CAN’T EXPLAIN YES ALLOWED
LIQUOR, AND WEED TO STAY OPEN
BUT SOUGHT TO PUNISH CHURCHES
AND SYNAGOGUES FROM OBSERVING
RELIGIOUS FREEDOMS.
HE SAID QUOTE, HE WASN’T
THINKING ABOUT THE BILL OF
RIGHTS AND SAID IT’S ABOVE HIS
PAY GRADE.
ABOVE YOUR PAY GRADE?
YOU HAVE FORGOT THE
CONSTITUTION?
DID YOU FORGET YOU TOOK AN OATH
TO UPHOLD IT?
NO MORE.
AMERICANS WON’T ACCEPT THEIR
RIGHTS BEING TRAM PRIME
MINISTERED ON.
NO MORE OF THIS ONE SIZE FITS
ALL THE MENTALITY.
22 MILLION JOBS LOST AND NOW
WASHINGTON RAN OUT OF MONEY TO
PAY FOR THE SMALL BUSINESS LOAN
PROGRAM?
LAYOFFS ARE THE PREDICTABLE
OUTCOME FROM THAT ONE.
AMERICANS SHELTERED IN THEIR
HOMES WATCHING THIS UNFOLD HAVE
SEEN THE DATA AND FACTS CHANGE
FROM DAY TO DAY.
FIRST IT WAS 2.2 MILLION WHO
WERE SUPPOSED TO DIE.
THEN 1 MILLION, 10250,000.
AND THEN 150,000.
BUT THE MODELS ARE JUST PLAIN
WRONG.
DATA POTENTIALLY LOWER DEATH
RATE.
WE UNDERSTAND THERE ARE STILL
MANY SICK AND DYING, AND DENSITY
AND HOT SPOTS ARE TO BE TREATED
DIFFERENTLY.
BUT WHAT ABOUT THE REST OF US?
WE WANT TO GO BACK TO WORK.
FEED OUR FAMILIES.
AND AS THE GOVERNORS SIT THERE
AND PONTIFICATE.
WE ARE THE ONES EXPERIENCING THE
REALITY FOR HE PERCENTAGE DROP
IN EMPLOYMENT THERE ARE 5,000 TO
6,000 DEATHS OCCURRING.
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
DRUG ADDICTION, LOSS OF HOPE,
BATTERED WOMEN LOCKED AT HOME
WITH THEIR ABUYERS.
ABUSED CHILDREN NOT BEING
IDENTIFIED OR PROTECTED BECAUSE
THEY CANNOT GO TO SCHOOL.
I WILL WEAR MY MASK AND GLOVES,
AND I WILL KEEP MY DISTANCE, AND
I WILL BE TESTED.
BUT DON’T THINK ABOUT TRACING OR
TRACKING ME OR GIVING ME A CARD.
IT AIN’T HAPPENING.
YOUR MODELS ARE OUT OF CONTROL.
THE ECONOMY IS OUT OF CONTROL.
CHINA IS THE ONE OUT OF CONTROL.
WE WON’T LET YOU DESTROY THIS
COUNTRY OR OUR WAY OF LIFE.
WE FOUGHT TO HARD TO LOSE IT TO
A WUHAN VIRUS THAT CHINA LIED
ABOUT, SAID IT COULDN’T BE
TRANSMITTED FROM HUMAN-TO-HUMAN
AND INTENTIONALLY PROTECTED
CHINESE CITIZENS FROM THE VIRUS,
BUT ALLOWED THE VIRUS TO BE
RELEASED, PUTTING THE REST OF
THE WORLD PAT RISK.
YOU POLITICIANS WANT TO FLEX OUR
MUSCLES?
START WORK ON HOW YOU ARE GOING
TO PUNISH, AS EXTRA ALWAYS EXTRA
BUT KEEP OUR DAMN HANDS OFF US
AND DO SOMETHING ABOUT WHAT GOT
US INTO THIS MESS IN THE FIRST